mais latente australien a paris il est
un diplomate cinq blessés graves et une
quarantaine plus légèrement l'élection
anticipée en allemagne helmut schmidt
ira seul à la bataille sans les libéraux
larmes israélienne reste à beyrouth
ouest après washington paris lui demande
de quitter immédiatement la ville
enfin la nomination des pdg de
l'audiovisuel trois nouveaux à radio
france daté et fr3 rien ne change à
antenne 2 et à la srt là messieurs
bonsoir les terroristes ont encore
frappé
cet après midi dans paris cinq personnes
ont été gravement blessées 43 autres
plus légèrement dans un attentat anti
israël
première hypothèse c'est une voiture de
la mission d'achat israélienne qui a
explosé dans le 17e arrondissement
devant les portes du lycée carnot
deuxième hypothèse ce serait un
cyclomoteur piégée qui était à côté de
cette voiture en tout cas attentat
criminel qui a touché cette fois des
enfants et des adolescents
et ce à la veille du jour de l'an juif à
15h25 une 504 du corps diplomatique
israélien garé au 68 de la rue cardinet
face au lycée carnot explose
la déflagration d'une telle violence que
la terre tremble dans un rayon de 100
mètres et salles de classe du lycée
carnot plein d'enfants à cette heure de
la journée ou à leurs vitres voler en
éclats
la fatigue et la faim
derrière leurs tables d'écoliers 44
enfants sont blessés par les éclats de
verre
il y avait trois personnes à bord de ce
véhicule qui appartient au service
commercial de l'ambassade
elles furent dégager après 40 minutes
d'effort zoltan landel diplomate de
l'ambassade d'israël son épouse veronica
et leur chauffeur l'occupé tout
s'apprêtait à fêter le nouvel an juif
oui je passais peut-être 3,4 secondes
avant que les séries n'explose ont été
au bout de la rue je suis arrivé le
premier pour sortir le conducteur de la
voiture de sa voiture il m'a simplement
dit avant d'être transporté à l'hôpital
que
c'est au moment où il a mis le contact
dans de sa voiture que la voiture a
explosé mais il se peut aussi que la
mobylette qui se trouve qu'ils se
trouvaient à peu près contre la voiture
et qui a fait un bond d'une vingtaine de
mètres entièrement calciné était et elle
est aussi plus j'ai deux enfants de 15
et 12 ans serait également gravement
blessé il était dans la rue au moment de
l'explosion
quant à leurs camarades nombreux sont
ceux qui ont été contusionnés par les
éclats vrai certains ont même été soigné
par une fleuriste tout près du lycée et
tous les gaz du lycée carnot qui sent
mieux certes gagner sinon c'est pourquoi
je suis tu es bon je vais gérer beaucoup
d'enfants qui ont été blessés exactement
pas super calme et beaucoup regard dîner
alors que les premiers blessés a été
emmené c'était l'émotion mais aussi déjà
la colère et surtout l'indignation
je considère que c'est un crime contre
l'humanité d'avoir mis une bombe de à
côté d'une école un véritable crime qu
une demi heure plus tard il y aurait pu
y avoir 100 de nos gosses déchiquetés
par l'explosion
de nombreuses personnalités se sont très
vite rendus sur les lieux alain savary
ministre de l'éducation les eaux sont le
secrétaire général du rpr monsieur pons
en compagnie de jacques chirac
on a aussi vu monsieur jospin secrétaire
général du ps venu pour témoigner des
motions des socialistes monseigneur
lustiger archevêque de paris qui avait
fait la confirmation des élèves
quelques mois auparavant
il apparaît
comme le grand rabbin de france monsieur
samuel rené samuel sirat avait déclaré
il ya quelques temps à la rue de la
victoire après ses horribles attentats
de la rue des rosiers faut que tous les
juifs de phrases assez que toute la
communauté juive se méfie fasse
attention d'un moment à l'autre on
savait qu'ils allaient qu'il allait se
passer quelque chose mais croire le
commissaire broussard ainsi que monsieur
franchise qui sont également venus sur
les lieux de l'attentât
le secrétaire d'état à la sécurité
publique a réaffirmé sa volonté de
prendre des mesures pour augmenter la
surveillance antiterroriste
une information judiciaire contre x a
été ouverte à la suite de cet enfant ça
c'est le 20e
depuis le début de l'été dans paris et
sa forme en ligne
oui aussitôt l'ambassadeur d'israël en
france mais rosen été reçus par pierre
mauroy à l'hôtel matignon qui lui a
exprimé son indignation et sa
participation à la douleur de la
communauté juive mais rosen appareils
pour sa part de provocation de la part
des terroristes à la veille je voulais
dit du nouvel an juif
le rush h1n1 il est impossible de citer
toutes les protestations qui sont
succédé sur les téléscripteurs de
l'extrême gauche au front national
toutes sont unanimes pour condamner le
terrorisme et dans l'opposition bien sûr
on appréhende différemment les
responsabilités des uns et des autres
déjà fin mars la mission d'achat du
boulevard malesherbes avait fait l'objet
d'un attentat attribué à l'époque à des
membres d'action directe et précisément
aujourd'hui
deux militants de ce groupe d'extrême
gauche dissous ont été arrêtés c'était
avant l'attentât de la rue cardinet les
policiers ont saisi au cours l'opération
15 kg d'explosifs
enfin une voiture suspecte a été
découverte tout à l'heure en
stationnement près du palais de l'elysée
il s'agit une voiture de sport qui
appartiendrait un saoudien sans adresses
répertoriées
les services de déminage sont sur place
me disent nous reporter la rue d'elysée
a été interdite à la circulation
peut-être des nouvelles dans le courant
de ce journal en tout cas voilà donc
pour ce 20e attentat à paris depuis le
20 juillet deuxième titre de l'actualité
ce soir la crise ouverte en allemagne
avec la décision du chancelier schmitt
de provoquer des élections anticipées il
souhaite une date rapide fin novembre ou
début décembre et se déclare prêt à
diriger un gouvernement minoritaire
c'est à dire sans les libéraux qui
depuis quelques mois il faut dire
multiplier les escarmouches à
l'intérieur du cabinet de coalition
michel meyer bonne
dernier mot du dernier discours de
combat de helmut schmidt en regagnant
son banc gouvernementale il est en effet
plus un sens seul y est minoritaire et
donc en sursis
c'est un lutteur qui l'a cependant
quitter un pouvoir qu'il n'exerce plus
que de façon formelle j'entends tombé de
boue avait il dit à ses proches et me
raser à l'avenir sans rougir de honte
c'est un blessé malgré les apparences le
symbole d'un divorce après quelques
treize années de coalition sociale au
libéral dès 9 heures ce matin
helmut schmidt avait confirmé la fin de
son gouvernement à des parlementaires
sociaux-démocrates qui dit sylvie lebron
ne supportait plus les manoeuvres
délibérons qu'ils accusaient de
démontage social et d'organismes
économiques
quelques minutes plus tard le chef du
parti libéral hans dietrich genscher
annoncé la démission des quatre
ministres libéraux de l'équipe
gouvernementale en présence de son ex
ministre des affaires étrangères et vice
chancelier qui avait regagné son siège
de député dans l'hémicycle il ne restait
alors plus à helmut schmidt qu'à battre
son jeu pour le chancelier seules de
nouvelles élections générales peuvent
mettre fin dignement à la crise et
rétablir la crédibilité de l'état envers
l'opinion allemande et internationale
au passage elle goûte mythe dénonça les
finasseries des libéraux avec lesquels
rien n'allait plus surtout lorsqu'il
s'agissait d'évoquer un plan
anti-chômage rédigé la semaine dernière
par le libéral graf lambsdorff helmut
schmidt a donc pris l'initiative
d'interrompre la longue agonie de son
gouvernement
ce faisant il attribue la responsabilité
du régicide aux libéraux désormais
contraint d'afficher publiquement leur
liaison avec les chrétiens démocrates
le leader chrétien démocrate et futur
chancelier helmut kohl n'est pourtant
pas tout à fait sûr de ses futures
troupes parlementaires autant
chrétien-démocrate que libéral dans son
intervention
helmut kohl qui d'ici quelques semaines
a toutes les chances d'être au pouvoir a
refusé de nouvelles élections
son intention est de renverser helmut
schmidt au profit d'un gouvernement de
coalition chrétien et libéral
cole craint en effet des élections
anticipées
- pour son propre parti que les sondages
donnent d'ailleurs victorieuse qu'en
raison du risque de disparition
électorale de ses nouveaux amis libéraux
cette journée ce 17 septembre a donc été
celle de la clarification sinon de la
clarté
en ce qui concerne l'avenir immédiat de
la politique allemande en effet on ne
sait pas exactement si dans les
prochains jours les prochaines semaines
il y aura véritablement la question de
confiance de helmut schmidt envers le
bundestag
on ne sait pas si la place sera faite
pour de nouvelles élections
on ne sait pas non plus si helmut kohl
et gagne cher le libéral et le
chrétien-démocrate réussiront à trouver
une majorité parmi leurs troupes leurs
propres troupes pour renverser helmut
schmidt et prendre le pouvoir former un
nouveau gouvernement
en tout état cause c'est vraiment la fin
de helmut schmidt la fin du locataire de
700 sellerie où il est resté quelques
huit années après washington paris est à
son tour de demander le retrait immédiat
de l'armée israélienne de beyrouth ouest
claude cheysson été très ferme il ya un
peu plus d'une heure
la france dit il juge indispensable le
retour immédiat de l'armée israélienne
aux positions qu'elles occupaient le 14
septembre
sous-entendu avant la mort du président
gemayel afin que soit engagé aussitôt la
négociation sur les conditions
d'évacuation de toutes les forces armées
étrangères du liban fin de citation mais
pour le moment jérusalem ne semble pas
apprécier d'obtempérer au contraire
l'armée israélienne s'est lancé dans de
vastes opérations de perquisitions et
parfois d'arrestations dans beyrouth
ouest y compris devant le quartier
général du mouvement
mourabitoun farouchement opposé à israël
est alliée traditionnelle des
palestiniens philippe rochot et jacques
doit y était il ya quelques heures
encore
la dernière poche de résistance que
rencontrent les forces israéliennes dans
leur marche sur beyrouth ouest se
trouvent ici nous sommes dans le secteur
de l'hôpital barbir c'est là que se
situe en effet la radio des mots rabhi
la gauche libanaise ainsi que leur
quartier général
il reste encore un dernier carré de
quelques 200 combattants à l'intérieur
de ce quartier
les forces israéliennes ont déjà avancé
de 500 mètres dans la matinée
progressivement elle avant
on faire la jonction avec les troupes
israéliennes qui se trouvent de l'autre
côté en bordure
du bord de mer elles vont ainsi fouler
dans la soirée la majorité de la ville
de beyrouth et on pourra dire que dès ce
soir les israéliens auront en main
toutes les rues de la capitale
pourtant ils en auront payé le prix
trois morts 70 blessés et trois disparus
en 48 heures selon les chiffres
officiels mais les derniers combats ont
eu lieu rue par rue
cette fois dans cette bataille de
beyrouth-ouest l'aviation n'est pas
intervenue et avec un renfort qui aurait
été de cent cinquante blindés et bien
souvent venue se rendre maîtres du
terrain
il faut dire aussi que sans l'appui
militaire des forces et palestiniennes
et combattant de la gauche libanaise ne
pouvait pas résister longtemps
ainsi en cinq heures de combat les
israéliens parvenait à encercler ce pâté
d'immeubles où se trouvent également
l'ambassade soviétique mais la radio
israélienne a démenti que de ça râle et
pénétrer dans les locaux
en début d'après-midi les forces de la
gauche libanaise ici sur la corniche
mazerat se rendait à l'armée israélienne
qui perquisitionnait alors dans les
immeubles pour rechercher les armes
alors qu'il est ne reste plus que
quelques poches de résistance mais le
couvre-feu a été ordonné à beyrouth
ouest
pourtant dans le reste de la ville le
calme régnait ce soir et l'armée
israélienne passait sans être inquiété
devant l'un des signes du parti des
nassériens indépendante
ces hommes qui avaient juré de résister
jusqu'au bout à la vente des troupes
israéliennes
mais l'entrée de tsahal dans une
capitale arabe laisse planer plus d'une
incertitude
même si l'armée israélienne a promis de
laisser la place à l'armée libanaise
dans les rues de beyrouth ouest
depuis hier soir déjà un candidat à la
présidence de la république libanaise
c'est le propre frère de béchir gemayel
tués mardi dans un assassinat dans
l'explosion du quartier des phalangistes
c'est donc amine gemayel qui souhaitent
perpétuer la tradition d'une famille
d'un clan un clan très unis comme en
témoigne ce reportage réalisé par gérard
spagli ya quelques années pierre gemayel
77 ans chef du clan fondateur des
phalanges faire de besiri damine c'est
la montagne libanaise
je suis sûr que c'est une des plus
belles régions au monde
cette neige et ça c'est mon grand père
mais ce n'est pas conçu cette maison
c'est une maison qui a quatre cent
trente cinq ans ça a été une des
premières maisons construites à bickfaya
c'est à dire que votre famille est une
vieille famille libanaise
oui c'est une des plus riches familles
libanaises nous sommes nés ici c'était
là et ça que cet attachement au liban
aux valeurs d'une certaine société
chrétienne implantée dans le monde arabe
pierre gemayel entendait les perpétuer à
travers ses fils dont il tenait à
s'entourer beaucoup l'esprit de famille
djemaï et beaucoup on se rencontrait
conservera dans ce sens mais la famille
est une chose le paletot est autre chose
est-ce que cela 2
jeune bas que vos enfants soient
pratiquement vos collaborateurs les plus
proches
c'est à dire que dans ma vie politique
mes enfants ne sont pas mes enfants sont
des des partisans des phalangistes et je
ne traite comme tel amine gemayel le
jour de l'élection de béchir recevant
les félicitations des députés est née
des fils 40 ans il s'était pourtant
effacé devant la forte personnalité de
son frère lui modéré homme de compromis
amin a conservé des relations avec
toutes les parties libanaises le 23 août
dernier la famille par la voix damine
avait indiqué le programme politique
qu'elle entendait suivre le programme
sélection nationale je m'habille de
conciliation entre toutes les
communautés tous les débats mais quelle
importance de débouler cette élection
alors
revenez pas d'un nouveau type pour
pierre dumayet le chef du plan aux côtés
de son fils amine la succession aura
maintenant un goût amer la politique
française maintenant avec les suites de
l'intervention de valéry giscard
d'estaing et hier dans l'heure de vérité
une entrée qui n'est pas passée
inaperçue déclarations trop abondamment
commentée ce soir encore dans la presse
et dans les milieux politiques en
première ligne pour les socialistes et
pour le gouvernement
pierre mauroy qui répond à l'accusation
sur la baisse du pouvoir d'achat en
france
allez y et l'argument complaisamment
répétées selon lequel nous aurions
décidé d'amputer le pouvoir d'achat des
français
monsieur giscard d'estaing là encore
utilisé hier soir à la télévision
or les agriculteurs par exemple peuvent
témoigner de la dégradation de leur
pouvoir d'achat durant le précédent
septennat non seulement monsieur giscard
d'estaing devrait être plus prudent mais
surtout ils devraient vérifier ces
affirmations
jamais nous n'avons programmé une baisse
de pouvoir d'achat dès son entrée en
fonctions en mai 81 le gouvernement a
arrêté au contraire un ensemble de
décisions destinées à assurer une
relance mesuré de l'économie française
après quatre trimestres de récession
cette relance était fondée sur un
accroissement du revenu disponible
visant particulièrement au travers de la
revalorisation du smig et des
prestations sociales les catégories les
plus modestes
l'objectif de relance conciliait avec
l'impératif de justice sociale et avec
l'exigence de maîtrise des équilibres
économiques
c'est impératif et cette exigence
demeure bien évidemment les nôtres c'est
trop facile de dire que le socialisme ça
ne marche pas alors que chacun sait bien
que lorsque la gauche parvient au
pouvoir c'est parce que la droite a fait
faillite c'est parce que le système est
en crise
eh bien nous relevons le défi
il prend les ministes d'en profiter pour
dénoncer ce qu'il a appelé l'étrange bal
des revenants tonalité très semblables
dans les propos du communiste charles
fiterman c'est une voix du passé que
nous avons entendu hier soir d'une mini
des transports un homme du passé un
homme dépassé ajoute en écho pierre joxe
le président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée en revanche cette prestation
de l'ancien président la république a
galvanisé l'udf qui réunissait
aujourd'hui ces parlementaires à
salon-de-provence ambiance euphorique
dit certain d'une décrispation -10 les
autres nous joignons jean-louis le scène
et daniel brême sur place soudain les
convulsions qui ont agité pendant l'été
les formations qui composent udf soudain
ses convulsions sont passés sous silence
à cela trois raisons giscard il hier
soir à enthousiasmer de la même façon
tout le monde sans exception et
aujourd'hui on ne lui reconnaît ici que
des qualités
en second lieu le meeting de ce soir
réunis de fait des personnalités aussi
différentes que jean lecanuet raymond
barre et simone veil des courants sont
donc respectées enfin troisièmement la
présence de jean claude gaudin à la
tribune véritable sinon du groupe udf à
l'assemblée qui a su éviter au parlement
de connaître les mêmes soubresauts qu'au
parti bref c'est ici une rencontre de
cohésion contre la gauche
l'opinion publique un soudainement pris
conscience de l'ampleur de l'échec
elle a compris quels sont les mots clés
de la politique socialiste impréparation
incohérences incompétence
irresponsabilité et intolérance
on aurait pu croire qu'en vingt ans
d'opposition
les socialistes avaient eu le temps de
beaucoup réfléchir et de mettre au point
des projets cohérents et bien non il est
clair aujourd'hui que 20 ans ne leur ont
pas suffi pour se préparer à gauche
berné la france il faut qu'ils
retournent dans l'opposition et le plus
vite possible
le discours le plus attendu est celui
bien cher de simoni on ne l'avait plus
entendu leurs meetings du dr depuis les
élections européennes de 1979
dans un discours de 25 pages aurel se
montre très sévère pour le couloir mais
également qu'ont ces propos a mis les
secours et les appels sans attendre à
préparer l'alternance enfin en vedette
américaine raymond barre plus économique
que jamais il s'est refusé à noter par
courtois sur l'heure de vérité de son
ancien président de la république
il conseillera tout à l'heure et à titre
personnel à l'opposition de ne pas se
comporter en marchands d'illusions ce
n'est pas le moment dit il de chercher à
plaire aux français car il faudra
entreprendre une longue marche des
lèvres la force de vue un ce nuage de
soir jean claude rouget qui à leurs
enfants par le coup d'envoi pour une
folle à marseille
l'absence des représentants du rpr qui
pourtant avait l'effet invité le temps
en tout cas paul amar unis des extraits
d'autres limites dans la nuit d'une
prestation qui errait change a scellé
les données du jeu politique
dans une certaine mesure c'est vrai que
le jeu politique comme vous dites été
faussé par le silence de valéry giscard
d'estaing il ne l'est plus l'ancien
président a parlé et a clairement laissé
entendre que le monde politique devra
désormais compter avec lui alors bien
sûr il n'est candidat à rien il l'a dit
et redit mais tout de même
ton de ces propos assez offensif et le
contenu de son intervention à ses
critiques à l'égard du gouvernement
n'ont laissé aucun doute
hier soir il ne sera absolument pas un
témoin de la vie politique française
mais bel et bien un acteur sans tomber
sur le site pour autant dans les
querelles de personnes alors une volonté
oecuméniques à l'égard des autres
personnalités de l'opposition qui auront
tout de même retenu une petite phrase
qui passe inaperçu ce matin l'opposition
n'a pas aujourd'hui un message suffisant
a dit valéry giscard d'estaing jacques
chirac qui incarne depuis 16 mois dans
une certaine mesure cette opposition n'a
pas réagi mais l'un de ses plus proches
conseillers alain juppé n'a pas manqué
de préciser ce matin sur europe 1 que
l'opposition avait un plan avec des
priorités claires et d'ajouter le chemin
pour les français ce n'est ni le
socialisme ni la restauration mais le
renouveau l'allusion est claire
alors on peut pas me considérer que la
majorité de pourrait se réjouir de cette
rivalité toujours tenace au sein de
l'opposition
elle pourrait le faire mais elle sait
que la rivalité entre deux partis
d'opposition et des biens de position
n'est pas forcément un handicap et elle
le sait bien l'année dernière à l'avant
le 10 mai la gauche était divisée elle a
pourtant gagné sans doute la raison pour
laquelle pierre moreau a réagi
aujourd'hui on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure avec beaucoup de vigueur en
répondant non seulement à valéry giscard
d'estaing mais aussi à jacques chirac et
raymond barre le premier ministre a sans
doute voulu s'adresser cette catégorie
d'électeurs qui a voté pour françois
mitterrand le 10 mai 81 et qui se pose
aujourd'hui des questions tous les
sondages le monde ses électeurs joueront
un rôle important en mars prochain lors
des prochaines municipales
et c'est tout l'enjeu du débat politique
cette année voilà vous le disiez jacques
chirac n'a pas commenté les propos de
l'ancien chef de l'état mais il ne l'est
plus aujourd'hui au gouvernement dont il
a dénoncé je cite l'attitude désinvolte
dans l'élaboration du statut de paris il
réunira son conseil municipal v que le
projet sera connu
enfin un mot encore sur la politique
pour vous dire que michel rocard a
réaffirmé aujourd'hui à castres sa
solidarité avec le gouvernement avec
lequel at il dit je n'ai aucun différend
la radio et la télévision on connaît
donc depuis ce matin les noms des
principaux présidents de sociétés du
nouveau à tf1 avec michel mais à fr3
avec andré hollow à radio france avec
jean-noël jamais rien de changé en
revanche la sfp avec bertrand labrusse
et antennes de toujours pierre
desgraupes philippe harrouard
choix le plus original celui d'un
universitaire de 40 ans jean noël
jeanneney à la tête de radio france
fils de l'ancien ministre du général de
gaulle cet agrégé d'histoire professeur
à sciences po
l auteur de plusieurs documentaires
télévisés le voici maintenant qui entre
dans le monde de la radio à tf1 c'est un
gestionnaire michel mais 57 ans qui
remplace jacques boutet monsieur mai
étaient depuis un an directeur général
de la fonction publique mais il n'ignore
pas pour autant les problèmes
audiovisuel puisqu'il a été dans le
passé chargé des problèmes économiques
alors rtf fr3 aura comme patron andré
hollow 61 ans également un gestionnaire
qui a été mise en vedette les derniers
mois en présidant la commission chargé
de répartir les fréquences des radios
libres de la radio à la télévision
il succède à dieter à l'antenne de
pierre desgraupes se succède à lui même
ce n'est pas une surprise
pierre desgraupes 64 ans est bien connu
des téléspectateurs puisque depuis
trente ans il collabore à la télévision
lecture pour tout cinq colonnes à la une
les médical il est pdg d'antenne 2
depuis juillet 81
enfin à la sfp bertrand labrusse est
reconduit âgé de 51 ans il va poursuivre
sa tâche au sein de la société française
de production où ils occupent des
responsabilités depuis trois ans état
stationnaire pour l'ancien premier
ministre pierre messmer qui est fière
été victime en compagnie du président du
conseil général de la moselle julien je
parte d'un grand l'accident de voiture
les deux hommes ont passé une bonne nuit
nous disent les médecins puisque nous
parlons actionne voiture sachez que
selon les médecins qui ont dispensé leur
soin à la princesse grèce c'est bien
elle qui conduisait la voiture
l'un de ses médecins le professeur lui
plaît avec hier soir fait étape d'une
attaque cérébrale
avant l'accident le très nombreuses
personnalités arrive depuis ce matin à
monaco pour assister aux obsèques dont
vous aurez un très large résumé dans
antenne 2 min demain plus de concorde
entre paris et washington et mexico
ainsi en a décidé charles fiterman seul
sera désormais desservie
la ligne paris new york et puis à
l'autre bout de l'échelle des transports
en commun le métro avec un plan anti
fraude annoncé par la ratp
faut dire que pour la seule année 81 400
mille infractions avaient été relevées
et que les fraudeurs ont coûté à la
régie environ 150 millions de francs
michel perron pratique de la borne
original le sceau de tourniquets est
désormais devenu le sport favori d'un
nombre croissant d'usagers 400 mille
infractions relevées en un an le nombre
de resquilleurs a atteint un tel niveau
que la ratp vient de décider la mise en
place d'un véritable plan de bataille
destinée à lutter contre la fraude
actuellement on peut ski mais quel
talent de 5 % de nos recettes provient à
chiper les enfants grandeur score
présente nitra par an
rendez compte on pourrait
d'acheter dix trains de plus 40
escaliers mécaniques de plus un petit
prolongement de lune c'est important ce
plan qui doit s'étaler sur plusieurs
années prévoit notamment de doubler
d'ici un an le nombre des contrôles dans
les rames et dans les stations
simultanément l'installation progressive
de nouvelles portes anti fraude devrait
supprimer la facilité et la tentation de
resquiller même si c'est parfois au prix
de difficultés pour l'usager ces mesures
sont enfin complétée par une campagne de
publicité par voie d'affichage
celle ci semble d'ailleurs diversement
apprécié par certains usagers qui n'y
voit qu'une image répressif et est clair
que dans cette lutte contre la fraude
il ya une part pour la répression des
infractions qu'ils ont commise et vous
posez la question à l'heure de savoir
quel était le type de fraudeurs
le joueur doit bien calculé son risque
car si elle est prise
peut-être assez lourde
très cher en effet il ne faut pas
oublier qu'une tentative de fraude peut
coûter jusqu'à 230 voire 1200 ou 3000
francs un mot encore pour vous dire que
le dollar était à nouveau en baisse
aujourd'hui 7 francs 0,6 mais que le
franc à la tête aussi deux jours après
la décision du gouvernement de lancer un
emprunt internationale et puis nous
passons au sport avec cette finale
attendue demain au championnat national
de tennis
noah contre lecompte gilles cozanet
de new york à paris de flushing meadows
et son public bruyant à l'ambiance
policiers du racing club de france il ya
tout un monde là yannick noah était
éliminée en huitièmes de finale
ici il disputera la finale après sa
victoire 6 7 6 4 6 3 6 0 contre thierry
tulasne il rencontrera dimanche henri
leconte qu'elle disposait de jérôme
potier dans l'autre demi finale et
devrait donc s'attribuer un quatrième
titre consécutif de champion de france
on comprend donc gagné noah qui
déclarait après son match après flushing
meadow j'ai l'impression de disputer un
tournoi de plage où je n'ai rien à
prouver ou à gagner
il ne disputera plus à l'avenir le
national épreuve qui lèverait apparaît
pour cette élise mène comme une
fastidieuse partie de campagne à côté
des fastes ce nom des solutions des
tournois du grand prix du grand chelem
voilà on va voir que c'était écrit dumez
quel temps il va faire deux pour les
finales nationales et puis ailleurs en
france il est bien encore une très très
belle journée demain malgré une tendance
vaguement rageuse qui est surtout située
sur l'atlantique mais regardons notre
cap satellite pour comprendre d'où nous
viennent ces problèmes eh bien ils sont
situés au large du portugal
ici et c'est cette dépression qui nous
amène des vents du sud en nous amenant
donc des orages sur la côte atlantique
si on regarde un tout petit peu plus
loin on s'aperçoit qu'une dépression ses
efforts mais sur terre neuve et qui ici
se trouve un petit cyclones ces deux
événements vont se rencontrer au milieu
de l'atlantique et nous amener du
mauvais temps sur la france mais ceux-ci
pas avant mercredi restons-en à demain
et voyons notre carte
plus précisément donc la tendance
orageuse va nous arriver par le sud
ouest comme les jours précédents il
restera encore quelques nuages dans le
nord-ouest de la france mais enfin rien
de bien grave quelques brumes matinales
en général malgré tout une très belle
journée est toujours très chaud dans le
sud du côté des températures c'est assez
simple 28 degrés à lille 25 à cherbourg
24 à brest ce sont des températures
correctes 28 à dijon voyez c'est tout à
fait convenable pour la saison on
dépassera probablement encore 30 degrés
dans la journée de demain pour le midi
demain le soleil se lève à 7h32
pour se coucher à 19h57 et c'est là sa
nadège et c'est aussi l'époque de la
nouvelle lune
voilà je vous rappelle le principal
titre de cette édition un nouvel
attentat anti israéliens en plein paris
aujourd'hui en plein après midi il
visait un diplomate sa voiture a explosé
à moins que ce ne soit un cyclomoteur
qui se trouvait face à côté cinq blessés
graves et une quarantaine plus
légèrement parmi lesquels des lycéens du
lycée carnot qui se trouvait juste en
face du lieu de l'explosion
hervé claude vers 22h50 devrait vous en
dire davantage en tout cas plus de
problèmes rude elysées après la
découverte d'un véhicule qui finalement
ne semble plus suspect j'aurai le
plaisir quand à moi de vous retrouver
demain soir à 20h bonne soirée à tous
sur un thème de disponible